you've got roommates or family members
and we've all got to agree on which
refrigerator we're going to get and you
got Ron DeSantis Trump and Joe Biden Joe
Biden's refrigerator is like from the
60s it's broken completely and he can't
even tell you what's going on come on
man he's just like all right let's have
questions he directs you to Kamala
Harris yeah I don't know what this is
and then Ron is giving you this very
very straightforward quiet low pitch and
then Trump is giving you this loud
boisterous we're gonna have the best
refrigerator mark my words and
everyone's like yeah yeah screaming I
want that one yeah well but hold on and
there's an important Point here which is
someone could hear that analogy and
still think I would choose the better
fridge and not the better salesman okay
that's true you would but this isn't a
question of us picking a fridge for our
house this is the question of us picking
a refrigerator salesman to sell the
fridge to the entire country
collectively by the way exactly what are
people going to buy like what are people
going to buy and I think part of the
criticism of trump is always oh he's not
dignified he's not presidential enough